the famous phrase god is dead appeared  for the first time in gay science he  understands the value and purpose of  religion but at the same time he wants  us to rethink our attitude towards  morality which until that point is  strongly interweaved with religion the  idea of god is a human production that  managed to synthesize societies for  centuries if we possess the thinking  capacity to create such a story that can  keep society together for so long surely  we have the resources to come up with an  alternative framework for morality  nietzsche also denounces the  otherworldly outlook of christianity its  emphasis on a better life beyond this  one zarathustra's philosophy is a  celebration of what is this worldly it  is a yes saying to life this life  for zarathustra like nietzsche thinks  that there is no other